oh yeah now it's now the show
now I get it
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by John Stamos I have
to say you're more handsome in person oh
my gosh I will take that I'm not getting
such a compliment coming from I didn't
know what to expect when I walked in
there but oh I saw you on TV but you're
just tall and you're you know you're
walking well thank you so wow all right
well let me get to you John he's an
actor producer and pop culture icon you
know from shows like Full House General
Hospital ER and many more and he also
has a brand new Memoir on the way doing
a funny brutally honest autopsy on his
40 years in Hollywood it's called if you
would have told me and it's due out this
October John Stamos welcome to the show
thank you if you would have told me that
I would be eating hot wings with you
today who would have believed who would
have believed who would think that a
show like this would be so popular
yeah I love I love watching it I love
growl was great on here oh thank you and
I know you had my friend Bob on which
was really beautiful loved that episode
I'm fascinated by this and by you hey
were you an interviewer or something
before yeah yeah cause you're so smart
man and and you rattle off these
questions I got some notes but but we'll
we'll see today we'll see today maybe
I'll I'll blow the whole Mystique for
you
I don't think so only time will tell you
ready to get started I guess
[Music]
thank you
oh the handle okay there you go
oh
what it's not very ladylike oh no I get
it I go but I'm not
great
foreign
if you would have told me is chock full
of encounters with some of the true old
Legend Titans of Hollywood and that's a
lot of celebrity Memoirs but I think the
difference with you is that you'll
maintain a relationship with Sammy Davis
Jr you'll become friends with Don
Rickles do you have any tips for
fostering mentors or older friends like
it just seems like a good life skill to
have for anyone who's just trying to
Mainline a little wit in wisdom it's I I
recommend it find some old you know
crusty guy that will tell you the truth
um sadly I've lost a lot of my good ones
you know but I just paid attention to
him like Rickles he became like a second
father to me he lost his son which was
really sad and and um and I but I always
wanted the it's kind of a weird thing
because like I wanted the best for him
all the time I got I was on ER at the
time and he was watching it he said how
do you learn all those lines I said why
did you just learn them and I went to
the producers said let's get Rickles on
here it'd be great you know okay and
they wrote him this big beautiful part I
know he would have won an award for it
and he and he the Knight before he's
supposed to start he the publicist calls
Dodge not doing it
starts tomorrow he backed out and I look
like an idiot you know and he called it
didn't talk to me for like a couple
weeks I was waiting for an apology and
we talked for a little while I'll talk
we used to talk like school girls we
talked for an hour on the phone and um
finally at the at the end he said I'm
sorry I didn't do that show I said okay
Don you can't we can't argue with him he
goes John um
I I couldn't remember those lines and I
didn't want to embarrass you
I love you he used to say uh keep my
name alive I'll get my name alive
so here we're keeping his name alive
what's the weirdest thing has happened
in the show oh so many weird things like
Aubry Plaza snorted milk I remember one
time Gordon Ramsay had like a milk fire
extinguisher that he blasted at me from
across the table he had like a whole
Mary Poppins bag of antidote
me and Dave Grohl actually I thought I
got drunk and everything yeah we did
shot for shot wing for Wing ended up
cleaning out an entire bottle of Crown
Royal and that was like a 10 a.m shoot
though
just stumbling out of this student with
a rock star you know crazy things have
happened so no matter what you're going
through on the show just know that way
weirder [__] has happened I'm in a wreck
I'm erect right now
so as a comedy nerd I've heard you talk
about how much you learned on the Full
House set working with Comics like Bob
and Dave yeah do you have a sense of
what makes a show like Full House work
on a foundational level or the
non-negotiables when it comes to
crafting a sitcom that endures the Full
House was I hated that show
I mean you know obviously I ended up
loving it but it was it was all it was
sort of pitched to me as um Bosom
Buddies it was Jeff Franklin who worked
on Buzz and buddies and Miller and
Boyette and Boos and buddies with you
know a couple kids in the background and
as we're casting it they're spending a
lot of time casting these kids that are
going to be in the background
we did a we did a table read of it and
that was the Stars coming in off of
General Hospital and all the mothers
were hell you know and I'm like okay how
are you doing in a big shot like I think
and we sit down we start reading and
Jody Sweetin who plays Stephanie reads
their lives and people are dying
laughing I mean screaming I was like
what's happening here like what was it
I'm slowly it's like she was getting
confidence and like boom knocking you
know home run home I'm like sleep they
couldn't even hear my lines they were
laughing so hard on her and I'm like
slinking down on my seat like this okay
and I run out to the I never forget I
run out to the lobby where the Century
Plaza Hotel and I'm digging in my pocket
for quarters like jam crying to get me
the [__] off this show to my age
and then we were like oh should we give
it a try and then Bob came in and I
fought it for a long time and then I
finally said what am I doing it's a
beautiful show we built with with
sweetness and kindness the show there
was no sexual character on that show is
what I realized the central character
was love
and that's we were the best
representation of a loving family not a
normal family
and it was The New Normal was now an
unconventional family so I guess that
was it I don't know
Crabby Shack here yep
I am Sean I have a wig on tonight and
I'm posting uh lemon pepper sauce sweet
sauce hot sauce you don't even know what
you're eating anymore I don't I have no
idea
every nurse I've already ordered
chickens or a slight bite out of each
anybody have it spit do you have a well
no there's a
there's a little can over there I won't
do that but it's there in case you need
to all right never say never
so in 2010 you want a golden icon award
for your performance and the Broadway
Revival of Bye Bye Birdie what did you
find that you gained from the stage that
you hadn't yet experienced on a TV set
it was like nothing else you can do
television you do movies you do concerts
they all happen at different times but
in that eight block radius where all the
theaters are at eight o'clock like
everybody everybody's gearing up to be
entertained today and all the
entertainers are getting ready to
entertain and it'll happen to right at
eight o'clock there's a spark that you
can feel like never felt that before I'm
boring you no I'm not this is one of the
most boring people out there going
theater what
these kids they don't know theater
um but uh I did something with Nick
Jonas you no well you did uh you did a
you did a Gore of it all play with like
Legends you're the Angela Lansbury and
James Earl James that was good
um hands down the greatest living actor
of of my generation and it was the last
night and I said you know James you
really gave me legitimacy working with
you and being in the show and uh you
know it's really taken me away from the
you know this mullet-headed thing that I
used to do and I'm proud of you so we go
out just as I'm finishing that the door
stage door opens and people are out
there for autograph screaming Uncle
Jesse Uncle Jesse
and as I look over and then I hear
everything they go uh James say Luke I
am your father Luke I am same thing
right right I look at him and we just
started laughing and it was a beautiful
moment which kind of goes back to the
philosophy it's like you can't fight it
you know yeah
um but did I answer your question
Fuego that means hot
I remember
[Music]
I used to work on my debt
did anybody just pass out a little bit
funny
no problem
um I should do that yeah pretend I
didn't say
um I used to work at my dad's restaurant
in Orange County I'm
we had these little green peppers like
this little chili yeah yeah thing of
them you know not eating those these are
good is a good I'm putting my hands on
and then one day I went to the restroom
put my hands up
um
that last one just came back up yeah
yeah yeah and I I haven't eaten hot
stuff since
he passed away where your parents at
um my mom's passed but my dad's still
around where where in Chicago yeah yeah
we play at uh Ravinia a lot do you ever
go to that yeah he loves Virginia he
loves Ravinia he's like season pass I
think it was there like the other night
tell him can we get him on the phone
maybe hold on somebody grab my phone
is he funny well I don't know I don't
know if he's camera ready we'll give it
a shot hold on let's put this on speaker
Chicago huh uh-huh
[Music]
come on hey Dad hi Dad I'm happy you
picked up hey um what are you wearing
I'm gonna put you on the phone with John
Stamos you're actually on the show right
now okay I'm gonna put you on the John
Stamos Mike
oh hi Mr Evans it's John Stamos
meanwhile he's going who the [__] is
this who's John Stamos I was just saying
I was just talking about um I'm on your
shows your son's show are you proud of
him
absolutely yeah it's a it's quite a show
um we uh I play with the Beach Boys you
know and we're at Ravinia every every
other year have you seen them
police boys he does know who I am oh
yeah thank you we did so oh your your
son said you have season tickets and
stuff not season tickets but light
seasons
boys last time we were down there so
cool
you saw these boys anytime we're there
you have front row seats backstage
passes on me I would love to meet you
and see you after before the show and
maybe even get on stage and sing Barbara
Ann with us
I'll take you up on that but thank you
sir uh very nice to meet you
I've already done that so
hey uh nice to talk to you and um I'll
see you at the next Ravinia show maybe
huh
okay thank you buddy
your son's making a lot of money by the
way
all right love you love you love you too
all right bye that's great that you said
I love you that's so beautiful
[Music]
bro
that's good I still love wings I just
don't eat them that much anymore because
you know
television
I get it I get it you know it's a
cross-eyed bear over here
I was fascinated by your grand scheme
podcast where you talked about the
kidnapping of Frank Sinatra Jr a story
that somehow flew under my radar even as
a true crime obsessive okay this story
is really like a Martin McDonough film
you know like there are so many absurd
twists and turns apart from me that made
me laugh was it's like uh you know Frank
Sinatra says you know I'll give you a
million dollars yeah right right give me
back my son and they're like oh a
million dollars we don't need a million
dollars we just want like 240 000 yeah
it was part of the script it was part of
the script and the dummy was talking to
Sinatra's you know you know he said he
said how much how much do you want and
the guy says 260 and the FBI was on the
phone was 260 million what the [__] are
we you know all I have is a million no
it's just 260 260 000 what
yeah it was crazy it was you know what
I've I sold it as a I brought him into
Netflix we sold it on you know right
away but this dummy wanted a million
dollars per episode get out of here and
then I let it go for a while and then it
I couldn't let it go so I did this part
did that podcast but
um I'm glad you you knew about it but
yeah
foreign
[Music]
let's add an element strip club no
I'm trying to get your leg
thanks I knew all the help I can get
over here I mean Zagat and Coulier went
to a strip club early on
we the show got picked up for another
season or something
we were in Culver City working
conversation let's go to a strip club
and Bob is always very like I'm too
famous
it's all right now put a hat on
everything
don't worry I know the guy's there I'll
take care of this Bob's got a hat thing
and we get there okay go do it just go
on the back okay thank you
and yeah coming here live look at this
the boys from Full House Uncle Jesse
give him a big round
hot ones live at the Rhino at the Rhino
at the Spearman Rhino how'd you know I
don't know I was just I guessed
so you live in New York where did you go
to New York to be a journalist
who's your favorite Howard what who are
the old guys the most formative like
people Letterman Howard and then I used
to listen to Loveline every night Adam
Carolla Jimmy was uh that was probably
like my Mount Rushmore growing like I
was like a weird kid like I'd put like
Howard on like
tape or like whatever and like right to
school and like listen to it at recess
and [__] like that really [__] weird
yeah yeah yeah or like my dad yeah my
dad was like a huge Letterman fan and
then he would tape like all the episodes
for the week and then he'd binge him on
the weekend and I'd like watch him watch
him and have him explain the jokes like
my mom's explaining songs like that was
the whole thing so yeah do you remember
the scene in in uh in Howard's movie um
you I felt like did you talk about an
interview where you said when he came
down as fart man and the whole thing
yeah yeah oh wow look at you yeah what
was it get the analogy so what
out early on like you know is the more
like why did my publicist put me on this
freak Show they walk into the room right
so that's how I was like making the
comparison to fart man fart man comes
down the whole crowd is going nuts he
blows up the podium with a giant fart
everyone's going crazy and then he walks
backstage and everyone's disgusted with
him you know what I mean so that's what
I was kind of like right right well
that's how he was on the radio people
[__] on him they thought oh he's a dirty
[__] you know and then all of a
sudden he did but here's my question for
you who in that scene uh he came he
comes down and it's MTV right now it's
MTV Movie Awards and what's his name who
introduces him it was um oh good
question
um like he goes hey ladies and gentlemen
um um oh yeah it was me good research
you [__]
oh God here's what who was it
you know oh I spend the whole week
researching every person that comes in
I'm talking about some parts I didn't
watch private parts you just talked
about it I didn't not this week sorry I
watched it not this week dude I'll tell
you about you you know the thing well
enough to be quoting it and comparing it
I'll tell you what I did watch go ahead
never too young to die we got to talk
about that all right fine let's talk
about that but but the story on that was
that Luke Perry Perry did it did anybody
throw that at you in one of these shows
um Luke Perry was was the guy who did it
on MTV for Howard and Luke Perry was I'm
not I'm too big to be uh to work with
you I heard on this shitty movie that
you're doing so he calls me at the last
minute hey stabbers could do me a favor
like he he bailed could you do it I'm
like yeah [__] yeah I flew out there I
mean slash were there all day drinking
beer and it was great that's amazing but
you didn't I wasn't that I guess
but you didn't know that that you would
have said you know listening it was in
this yeah I'm picturing the scene I
already know it's like a low camera shot
it's like to the ceiling the blue on the
stage
someone introduces them who was it who
was it who was it was it Rob Lowe
so all the comedians the bet on here
haven't rubbed off on you
that was good brother okay
[Music]
do you ever have co-hosts on this thing
no why are you auditioning yeah
this one wow are you for real I'm fine
[Music]
I was a joke
I do my own stunts
um
it's not that bad
you're taking it better than I am
this one's never easy for me
look at you
I'm humbled on this side of the table
you're nailing this co-host uh audition
you think yeah
it gets hotter yeah it's sneaking up
yeah
I know
oh yeah now it's now it's the show
now I get it
[Music]
I just do anything
I've never seen anyone try that move
no no
oh I know I know never easy never easy
that's eight that's eight that's it
so I understand that you once outbid
Michael Jackson well one of the original
Disneyland signs I can't hear their
steam coming out of my ears of all the
Disney memorabilia and ephemera that
you've collected over the years is there
one that you would call your Holy Grail
that's what I get
you guys set me up didn't you smoke
painted you oh these were just normal
ones from Roxbury farmer
ah I know I know
Disney was they had a warehouse full of
stuff the first thing on the auction was
the big gigantic sign outside of Harbor
Boulevard Michael Jackson wanted it it
was going to go for a million dollars
but I forgot about it and then I was my
office and I put it on and I was like oh
[__] I'm winning this thing I think it
was like an hour left refresh refresh
refresh call my business I said I think
I want to win this sign 32 Grand okay
how big is it like 14 by eight not 14
inches bite 14 feet but each letter
Sports if this gets hotter as you yeah
you're talking I know 14 feet by eight
feet so they had to you know helicopter
didn't oh thank you
this is what killed seconds
he would do that joke if he was alive to
me he wouldn't have waited a year and a
half either keep it alive keep the name
alive
he would say the worst things
yeah that was terrible
and what goes into it okay
here we go
so it's hard but not not as
it's hot but it's not like the last one
okay
not a glass
is it true that you watched Bobby Knight
to study the best way to throw a chair
when he took on the role of a
temperamental basketball coach in the
Disney Plus show Big Shot
they don't even have cue cards either
I'm not being funny like you're so good
at this
[Music]
um are you a sports guy I am a sports
guy I know you're not a sports guy it's
interesting then to me that you'd like
you know you're spending time with Jerry
West you're studying the film on Bobby
Knight and I'm curious it was like a
non-sports guy how you kind of like
absorb that I had an easier time with
the with the medical jargon on ER than
than sports stuff on on big shot so I
mean I just did my research I studied
and
um yeah a friend of mine knew Jerry West
so I went to you know to meet him and
hello Mr West thanks for allowing me to
come to this rehearsal today and first
of all it's not rehearsal practice
uniforms
and he was funny and I and I did some
jokes about him you know like on talk
shows when I was trying to promote it
how dumb I was and he said and then he
went on some and said that boys he was
so convincing he was so real I was so
proud of him he really seemed like a
real Coach Jerry West was managing the
um Clippers right and I thought they
were a college team and that pissed him
off like if they're not right no I
thought they were Pros they were pros
and
um but I thought they were College
because I played a college you know
coach I thought maybe you know oh it's a
college team
all right John
this is great fun thanks for having me
all right this is the last one do I get
to will you send anything home with me
you get all the sauces you get every go
ahead
take a look around
okay
everyone got this in your eye or
anything yeah every hot sauce mistake
that you can make I've made like when
you told that story about the green
chilies and whatever I've done that
cross-pollination mistake I've gotten
sauce in my eyes
everything every possible hot sauce
mistake you can make cheers cheers John
you have a purple do that
the wings of death John a distant memory
all right you've taken on the hot ones
Gauntlet lived until the tail and to
close things out what I want to do is
put you to the test a little bit we have
a couple pairs of drumsticks here I'm
curious if you can teach me some sort of
drumstick trick okay which might be a
challenge with our fingers soaked in hot
sauce over here okay
but let's give it a shot
wow I thought we were gonna eat more
wings
what do you want to learn
whichever do you want to try a
paradiddle because yeah that's right
that's a common
um
uh so it's right left right right left
right left left
right
[Music]
left right left that's good that's hard
there we go
[Music]
I broke the table
you want to learn how to spin them here
put the put the put the stick you have
clearly halfway through there now just
kind of whip it around like oh how'd you
do that well like this oh wow see
that's incredible yeah
now I know why you know
I'm kidding kidding
I had that but if we this will get you
chance we should literally yeah I'll
give you a good drum message all right
well I'll take you up on that John
Stamos and look at you taking on the
wings of death living to tell the tale
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life oh I
saw this bit
I have a book called if you would have
told me
and that's it but I'm gonna tell but
what I have going on is this episode is
going to be airing soon and I'm going to
have a whole party that's why I want to
take some of these when I leave I'm
going to have a party and and and
everyone I'll make everyone you know do
it play along at home love that will you
come over I will definitely I will be
there I will be there
what a pleasure
he just said they're never gonna air it
he whispered in my ear this is so great
did I get the job
you're hired
you're beautiful you look beautiful eyes
foreign
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans and if you've ever watched
hot ones and wondered to yourself how
hot are those sauces really I could get
through that with no water or milk well
now is the time to put your money where
your mouth is the hot ones season 21
lineup is now available in its entirety
at heatness.com heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 21 hot Ones hot sauce lineup milk
not included be careful around the eyes
and get them while they're hot
mother